fakt ist in diesem jahr konnte man bei
diversen reformations veranstaltungen
wirklich viel geld verdienen zb als
lauter jubel und ein mann der das völlig
erfolglos versucht hat ist gernot
hassknecht werte damen und herren
[Musik]
ja wahnsinn oder wie aus dem gesicht
geschnitten werden
also jetzt nicht aus dem gesicht von
luther aber trotzdem schön sein welches
maul halten
der westfälische bauern kreml es ist
nutzer jahr und das muss gemolken werden
basta buchen sie den partie luther ich
mache auf betriebsfeiern und in der
geburtstage
das würde mir jetzt noch ein bisschen zu
kommerziellen muss schmerzt ich habe
mein ganzes geld in nutzer fanartikel
gesteckt wenn ich den scheiß jetzt nicht
verkauft kriege ich das 500 jahre auf
dem tempel hier playmobil wie zb die
haben eine million mal ihre hässliche
luther figur verkauft sieht aus wie
prinz eisenherz mit dem crossfader das
hat doch mit dem historischen luther
überhaupt nichts zu tun hier
das sind szenen die zu original luther
zitaten passen
luther hat zum beispiel gesagt wie
zauberinnen sollst du nicht leben lassen
ich will der erste sein der feuer an sie
legt und danach schöner will die frau
nicht zukommt
die geister mütter zitate hören sie alle
beim einer lesung zb auch eine frau hat
häuslich zu sein
frauen haben nämlich einen breiten
protex und weiter hüften dass sie sollen
stille sitzen und natürlich die ganzen
antisemitischen sachen die kommen gerade
im osten immer sehen ja wie gesagt ich
finde zu kommerziell sei ernsthaft jetzt
wer braucht denn bitte so was ihr den
luther schnaps die sonderbriefmarke
kondome kleine badeente hatte der
geistliche bestimmt auch schon dann
haben wir ein was ich die touristen
mitnehmen können dann in kirchheim
man merkt wie gibt's auch diese kreation
die luther-bibel mein herzhaft salami
tisch so großartig die luther-bibel
ausland und wissen sie was liebe
zuschauer
ich habe noch genau zehn exemplare da
muss ich muss einfach verrückt sein
diese leckere nutzer salami in den
horben also letztlich eine salami
kritik hast du dann problem mit rufen
sie jetzt an und buchen sie den party
luther gerne auch für ihren
junggesellinnenabschied ladies zahlen
sie sich auf das hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]